all right we're learning new details
about the criminal history of a man who
allegedly claimed to be Timothy Pizza an
Illinois boy who disappeared nearly
eight years ago police say the man is
actually Brian renamed a 23 year old was
released from jail less than a month ago
Adriana Diaz is in Newport Kentucky near
where Rini allegedly first claimed to be
Timothy Adriana good morning good
morning it was actually on this block
when rainy appeared allegedly saying he
was Timothy Pitts n' we spoke to people
who lived here and they say he looked
tired fidgety and scared
Timothy pizzas family says they feel
pity for reading but they're shattered
and left to pick up the pieces
once again that's kind of back to Ground
Zero for us Timothy Pitts ins family
says they never gave up hope he would be
found but this week's promising break in
the case is now heartbreak it's
devastating
yeah it's like reliving that day police
were called to a Kentucky neighborhood
Wednesday after people reported seeing a
person acting suspiciously he looks
scared yeah Friday night says she saw a
man ducking behind cars and moving away
when people got close I kind of thought
that he was out there up to no good
period according to a police report the
man told them he was 14 year old Timothy
Pitts Tsin who'd gone missing in 2011 he
allegedly said he'd escaped his
kidnappers but a DNA test proved
otherwise he has not Timothy we've had
confirmation from the detectives police
say the man was actually 23 year old
Brian Rainey
according to Ohio corrections records
Rainey has a lengthy rap sheet including
past charges over false statements he
served more than a year in prison for
burglary and vandalism and was released
less than a month ago on parole
the real Timothy Pitts and went missing
when he was 6 years old around the same
time his mother was found dead in a
motel room of an apparent suicide she
allegedly left a note that said Timothy
was safe but would never be found I just
miss my son and I wish he was here
in 2011 Timothy's father James Pittston
spoke to our CBS Chicago station WBBM he
made a direct appeal to whomever had his
son I forgive you for having my son just
wish you would
drop him off in the hospital police
department then he can come home with to
his family now the family's appealing
again but this time for prayers we know
that you are out there somewhere Tim and
we will never stop looking for you
praying for you and loving you the FBI
isn't commenting about whether Rainey
will be charged but Rainey's brother
Jonathan spoke out yesterday apologizing
to the Pitts and family he something
hasn't spoken to his brother in years
but called him quote nuts and said he
wasn't surprised by the incident Gail oh
boy Ariana it is heartbreaking and
bizarre thank you so much there's so
many questions did he have any knowledge
of Timothy Pitts and he gives his name
and his birth date he just appears out
of jail and we all got our hopes up yeah
we really did no so disappointed here
that you know and what this poor family
went through through this whole thing
yeah so many questions are still